[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Good afternoon.
Well, actually, it's
still the morning.
So good morning, Google
I/O Live Stream viewers.
Welcome.
I'm Natalie Villalobos,
Women in Technology
advocate here at Google.
And I'm sitting with
Aheri Stanford-Asiyo.
She is an incredible
woman who has recently
been working with the
Hack4Congress competition
to solve for amazing
things in the world.
Welcome, Aheri.
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO: Thank
you so much for having me.
It's a pleasure.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So
how did you get started?
Actually, tell me a little
bit about your background.
You have a fascinating
background.
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO:
Well, I agree.
It's not entirely common.
I was actually recruited
by the federal government
back in-- this was back in 2005.
They were hiring for
security professionals.
And I had an international
studies degree,
was teachable, and passed
a number of intelligence
and writing and tests.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Did you have
physical stamina tests as well?
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO: We'll
get into that really later.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: OK, OK.
I just don't know if Hollywood
is depicting it-- in my mind,
you're, like, running
miles with bricks.
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO:
You've totally
got to go through
the clearance process
before they even get you
physically out there.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Ready.
OK.
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO: But in
case, they went, hey, you know,
she's trainable,
she's teachable,
and we need some people to train
up as security professionals.
And so I took a role
fresh out of college.
And really just learned how
to protect people, facilities,
and information.
And that involved a lot
of really cool technology.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: And
what three-letter agency
was this, again?
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO: So
I was hired by the CIA.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: CIA.
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO: Yes.
A lot of people go,
oh, is that NSA?
Very hot topic, of course.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
There's a lot of acronyms.
So when you bring this
up, what do people do?
Do they usually shrink away?
Do they lean in?
Do they want to know
classified secrets
and you've just got to,
like, shut them down?
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO: Wow.
So as a security officer, I am
very attentive to other folks'
reactions to this.
And frankly, we live
in a world now where
people are really becoming
very, very sensitized to issues
of government surveillance.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah,
Big Brother-y type feeling.
Yeah.
AHERI STANFORD ASIYO:
Big Brother thoughts.
And so naturally, they
kind of want to go,
OK, are you a part of
the Empire, which is sort
of covertly plotting against--
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Which
may mean "Star Wars."
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO:
That's fair.
Right.
No, there's a fair
amount of curiosity.
But frankly, I'm accustomed to
being more observant of where
that curiosity is
coming from than sort
of taking a perspective
of what's more common.
I would say the most common
thing is just curiosity.
And then maybe a
little protectiveness.
Is there anything that
you can't tell me?
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Or do
you know everything about me?
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO: Right.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So you
did that for many years,
working with them.
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO:
About eight years.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
And now you're in
the tech world.
How did you land here and why?
AHERI STANFORD
ASIYO: Good question.
Sure.
Well, first of all, it's
always been a passion for me.
I was lucky enough to grow up
in the Research Triangle Park,
an area of North Carolina.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Yeah, I've been there.
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO: It's
a great place to grow up.
Actually, they say
it's the highest
per capita PhDs in the country.
Maybe that's an old statistic.
But we're talking about Raleigh,
Durham, and Chapel Hill.
And they, of course, have
excellent universities,
one of which is Duke University.
And as a result of
really just interacting
with a lot of folks, including,
well, both of my parents--
my father, a student, and my
mom working in the IT department
at Duke.
Just it was easy for it to be
sort of dinnertime conversation
to talk about how binary
works or token ring, which
IBM and token ring, I've just
dated to, like, the early '80s.
And that's a little
embarrassing.
I was eight in 1988.
This is awkward.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
It's all good.
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO:
But the reality
was that I was exposed to
kind of the realities of how
problem-solving can be done
with computers very early.
And later on, I think that
really made it possible
for once I had come out of
my undergraduate education,
it was easy for my
supervisors and colleagues
to see that there was some
complex technology that
made sense to me in a
different way than perhaps
a lot of my predecessors
in security positions.
So that really kind
of, I think, led
them to shift me over to
supporting more advanced work.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
So it's cool.
So you had mentors or
people who saw that in you
and wanted to give you more.
It's a success problem to take
on more responsibility, right?
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO:
That's always true.
And it's natural for
employers to want
to push you to be of the
highest use and value.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Right.
And so the Hack4Congress
competition,
you were saying it was your
first competition and foray
into the tech industry.
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO:
That's correct.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
How did it go
and what were you solving for?
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO: So
it was a wonderful event.
This was over two days over a
weekend in March of this year.
And the first thing
that I think of
is kind of the crowd
that convened there.
We're not talking
about folks who
were sort of independently
coming up with how they wanted
to build something,
and then coming,
and sort of presenting
these as solutions.
These were folks who are
committed to civic tech, people
who recognize that our
government lacks efficiencies,
and that there are
civil servants who
want to do the right thing, and
yet may not have the ability
to do that, or are
barraged with information.
And that goes all
the way up the line,
from congressional
staffers who are
running around trying to
assist people, representatives
themselves.
Darrell Issa was a huge
proponent for Hack4Congress.
And he was very frank
about the big problem,
which is there's stuff
that human beings miss.
And yes, I'm a congressman,
but guess what?
I need regular folks'
help to see where
attention needs to be put.
So convening a group of people
who kind of have their antennas
up about these
realities really meant
that we ended up kind of
hacking some cool ideas.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Is there anything
you can share about
what you successfully
found in these projects?
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO: Of course.
Of course.
So the team that I
ended up on really
hyper-focused on the issue
of campaign finance reform.
Now, that is really
a behemoth issue
and one that is not
something that can be solved
in a weekend, so to speak.
But what we did do and
what was exciting about
it was that we essentially
designed a mobile solution,
through which folks can very
easily connect their own values
with the values that are
being shown through voting
and bringing bills forward for
votes by area representatives.
So for instance, if I'm
very, very concerned
about public schools in
my area and that's really
my top concern, then I can
drag and drop that issue
to the top of my
profile and choose
two other issues under that.
And I can immediately
hit Match Me.
And through some very
interesting recommendation
engines, can see
representatives who
match that profile through
their voting history,
through some of
the Sunshine APIs
that have been invented just
by some of the nonprofits,
especially in the DC area.
So the whole point
is really to be
able to find a
matching point, where
people are engaged through
issues with representatives
or candidates who are
interested in the same ones
or who have priorities that
are aligned with theirs.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: And I
think that's really great.
You expressed a user
interface that seemed
really intuitive, really easy.
And it's really
nice because I know
that just even
when I'm voting, I
get sent, like, paper
pamphlets and update pamphlets.
And I'm just overwhelmed.
Like, I don't know what
is the latest version.
And I just end up going
with estimated guesses,
maybe whoever's name
I've heard the most.
And a lot of my friends
will actually get together,
and they'll host kind
of get-togethers,
and you have to defend topics
that you normally wouldn't want
to defend in a voting season.
And we try to have
these education parties.
Sometimes I just
can't get to them.
I love what you're doing-- is
you're making this process more
accessible to everyone
in a way that we're all
starting to come
into, and having
these mobile technologies.
And so I think it's
really awesome.
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO: Thank you.
What you're talking about,
I think, is a growing trend.
But there are a
lot of folks that
are being left behind
who aren't in crowds
where that's more common.
And to make that possible is an
interest that I have, for sure.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
And so at Google I/O,
are there specific
platforms or tools
that you feel are good for these
civic innovation ideas that
are going to drive the future
of getting more of the public
to participate with
the government?
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO:
That's a great question.
So there are some
technologies that I was really
excited about.
In particular,
during the keynote,
there was some discussion
around something
called Loon, which is
really-- I mean, anyone who
wasn't able to catch the
keynote or what have you,
should Google it.
But why it's so exciting
to me is for instance,
my parents live in an area
where their internet service
is pretty much hit or miss.
And in the age of
technology, it's
imperative that they be
able to be in access.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Access
to information is important--
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO: Exactly.
That's key.
That's part of our evolution
as humans, I believe.
So what Loon is
capable of doing is
providing a service through--
really, it's a physical device.
It's hey, we're going
to put this in the air,
and it lasts for about 100 days.
It's around the same ideas
that the government uses
for transmitting communications
data using satellites,
but it's below the stratosphere.
It's lower down to the ground.
So it's basically allowing
low or no connectivity areas
to be able to be online.
So to me, that is where
the democratization
of technology and
civic involvement
are permitted to meet.
When everyday people become
linked in with their neighbors,
with their families,
with their neighborhoods,
and then out into
the wider areas,
they're already
being represented
and laws are being passed
that affect them every day.
But if they don't have
that two-way communication
mechanism, then democracy
really isn't working.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: And so
it's this pervasive knowledge
economy that you're
creating with the work
that you're doing,
and blending it
with this innovative
technology that we're starting
to see pop up in the industry.
So last question.
And you've already solved for so
much, I feel, in your lifetime
that you've got a
whole lifetime to go.
So what do you
want to see solved
for in the next 50 years?
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO: Wow.
Wow.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Or 10.
We can go to two.
We can go to one.
What is the thing that
you're most passionate to see
solved for?
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO: So I
have two diverging responses
to that, truly, because
the world is represented
by very different populations.
And we see a very
narrow field of it,
being in a developed country,
where we are in access easily
to food, water, shelter,
and information.
There's another
part of the world
that we don't see every day,
where those things are not
taken for granted.
So my initial
response is, well, I
would love to see materials
design ideas really
coalesce into products
that can allow
us to have flat screens
this small on my wrist.
But on the other side of
it, perhaps material science
can help me to create a water
bottle that very, very quickly
filters what would otherwise
be non-potable water
to make it potable.
Those are the kinds of
technologies or tools
that I'm also interested in.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Very cool.
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO:
And that is,
I think, at the core of
what I would call tech,
because we're
talking about tools.
We're talking about using
existing materials to make
something new that's useful.
And that's really kind of the
intersection of my interest
in making things.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Well, thank you so
much for being with us today.
It's been a pleasure getting
to spend time with you.
I'm certainly inspired by
the way that you're doing.
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO: Thank
you so much for having me.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Please come
back again to I/O next year,
and perhaps you'll be
on a stage talking to us
about what you've created.
AHERI STANFORD-ASIYO:
You're so kind.
Thank you very much.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Thank you so much.
Thanks.